It turns out that i to the 5th equals i, i to the 6th equals negative 1, i to
the 7th equals negative i, and i to the 8th equals positive 1. Fantastic
pattern solving, if you found those. Now, I know these are pretty tough. So,
it's okay if you stumbled. Let's see how to do it. For the first one, we have i
to the 4th times i. We know i to the 4th already. That equals 1. So, we can
replace i to the 4th with 1. This leaves us with 1 times i, which equals i. For
i to the 6th, we can rewrite it as i to the 4th times i squared. We know i to
the 4th equals positive 1 from before. And we know that i squared really equals
negative 1. So, we can replace that here. We multiply these numbers together to
give us negative 1. For i to the 7th, we break it down into i to the 4th times
i cubed. i to the 4th equals 1, and we know i cubed is really equal to negative
i. So, that's how we simplify i to the 7th to be negative i. And finally, for i
to the 8th, we'll have i to the 4th times i to the 4th. Both of these equal 1.
So, we'll have 1 times 1, which equals 1.